- Alright, let's do this.
Oh shit. Okay, I'm sorry.
Today we're going to see if someone
with no haircutting experience
can give a decent haircut.
(whirring)
- You suck.
- I think I can give
Brighton a decent haircut.
I'm gonna try really hard.
Hopefully, I don't screw it up.
- No, I don't think I'm
gonna give a great haircut.
- My name is Derek
Henriksen and I'm a barber
and I've been cutting hair for five year.
I currently work at Union
Shave in Saugerties, New York,
an all American barbershop.
I'm here to judge the amateur haircuts
and I'm gonna fix them
when they're finished.
I don't think these haircuts
are gonna turn out well.
- Are you terrified?
- Yes.
- What kind of haircut do you want today?
- Can you try to give me a tight fade
on the back and the sides and
then keep it long on the top?
- Just a trim at the
top, not going too crazy
because, again, I don't trust Sean.
- Here we go.
I'm feeling really confident right now.
I'm liking how this is going.
How do you feel? Do you feel okay?
- I'm sweating really bad.
- Are you really?
I'm sweating 'cause I'm so nervous.
- I'm feeling confident,
I dunno about Jay.
- Dude, your hand's
pretty shaky right now.
- How do you think I'm doing so far?
- Doing Good.
- Good?
- [Producer] Is this a good approach?
- Yeah, I mean, he's doing alright.
- Does everything look even?
- Yeah.
It might not be that bad.
- I'm confident that
he will really like it,
so I'm gonna start moving on to the front.
I'm sorry, I see this right here.
- I'm really concerned
about the top portion here.
'Cause this is, really
you can't screw this up.
- Oh no.
- That is not what I want to hear.
- I know.
- I think I'm gonna thin it out first.
How do you like your
hair, do you like it thin?
- No, let's just give it
a short trim at the top.
- Alright, so I'm gonna thin it out first.
I have no rhyme or reason
for what I'm doing.
- I'm so sorry.
This was good.
- I'm just gonna take a chunk here.
- Stop saying that.
That's my ear.
That's my ear again.
- Ooh, got some skin.
I'm gonna break tskin.
- Alright, Brighton, it's done.
- What do you think?
- Looks good.
- Not bad, not half way,
half decent job, Jay.
- Half decent job.
- [Producer] Cool, wanna grab
the mirror for the reveal?
- [Sean] Yeah.
- Would you like to see it?
- I don't know if I want
to, but I guess I should.
- What the fuck did you do?
- [Sean] It looks good.
It looks good, other than
the little patchiness here.
- [Female Barber] Can you see the back,
can you see your bald spot?
- Right there? Oh my god!
- Overall, this, my bad.
The bald spot on the back, whoops.
But like, if you don't look at
this side, I think that's not
I don't think that's that bad.
And the styling, I think
the swoosh is still in,
I think it's a thing.
I'm really proud of myself.
- My plan to fix this is
I have to try to find what this length is,
and even this whole top
out, bring down these sides.
Oh yeah, it's salvageable for sure.
For your first, first
time, or second time,
it wasn't so, so bad on the sides,
the top was more of the issue.
I kinda was able to take
it down a little bit on top
and just even it a little.
- Looks great.
- Yeah, looks good now.
- I think I came into
it thinking short hair,
more masculine cut, I could just
buzz it off, I dunno it
was just a lot of layers.
- It was about what I expected.
It was very, very difficult.
But I think at the end of the day,
he didn't have to do much.
I think this is kind what it
looked like when I finished.
(laughing)
So I think I found
myself a new profession.
(easy music)